freakin right I think we kind of grew up
with them like last week hi guys i'm
daniel radcliffe here at the grove
theater today right now there is a
screening going on of the movie what if
which I am in and the people that
watching it think that afterwards they
can be sort of doing short interviews
about the film but in a cunning and
hopefully joyful act of deception I will
be hiding in the room and will make
myself known to them at some point it
will be hilarious now that they just
don't react at all but we're hoping that
they kind of do so what did you think of
the movie I thought it was adorable very
relatable it was really funny it was
like really whimsical it was like Harry
meets Allie but I felt like it was like
a real-life love story yeah I don't know
I'm Dan this was a design act
exceptional I'm sorry for you make me
more comfortable I can
nice to meet you Valerie how you doing
oh okay hi
oh my god
oh my god I'm doing ocean and I'll
forgive Mouse me as well
oh my god Oh awkward hi Dan nice until
you enjoy it it was so I know this
relates to her quick to immediately be
asked about your feelings by someone
who's in the film but yeah thank you cuz
I was like back there going like when
they said like what do you think the
movie I was just like hey he did it like
what would you be on if we said we hated
it I think I just have been like don't
look at the next 19 me likey like
reacted before you even touch it sound
like your dream or nightmare has just
come clearly how is this well thank you
very much but I feel kind of bad doing
this to so many people like I'm just oh
but no it's lovely is really okay thank
you very much great that was me scaring
out of a bunch of people um which is
always fun it is always nice to like mmm
get that kind of genuine reaction from
people I do yeah I'd never normally kind
of like do it in that kind of hey it's
me way I don't do that to people on the
street just so everyone knows um but ya
know it was it was great fun and I
definitely I was just sitting back there
worried that like they were gonna be
talking that later hate film and they
just wouldn't be at all pleased to see
me when I came up so I was just
delighted that David there would be idea
I didn't think it was real I was like
you definitely it like it like me a
ghost or something and he's there and I
was here and I was like she's right
there and I'm right here and I was like
woo he's right there he came up right
beside me and my instinct is to punch
people I almost punched Daniel Radcliffe
it was true what oh my gosh I don't even
feel like it's real life yeah yeah I
feel like I was the dream like I was
sleeping this isn't real
I think it just shows that how down to
earth you
like I'm sure nobody would accept like
yes no yeah yeah